how do you know when something good has
happened the left implodes immediately
afterwards take the tax bill which is
twisted democrats into bitter pretzels I
mean when you're saying the bill
benefits the rich then you call the
millions of rebates crumbs you look
stupid
it's like noting that a chef is fat
while he's cooking free meals at a
shelter so the tax bill must be awesome
because the hits keep coming the Dems
actually want to repeal it and I hope
they try in a recent Town Hall Nancy
Pelosi claims the bill was passed in the
dead of night a massive lie even for her
fact we knew more about the tax bill
than we know about her immense wealth on
the five we debated the damn thing for
months
none of us loved it completely because
we knew what was in it
unlike Obamacare a flaming mess dumped
on America's porch at midnight haha then
there's this if what you're doing is
cutting the taxes at the high end and
therefore not being allowed to invest in
the future you're doing a grave
disservice to our country yeah so the
bill is unpatriotic how so are those
millions of bonuses coming from
corporations unpatriotic I guess if it's
not from Nancy's pen that it's treason
or is it the wage increases that came as
a direct result of the cuts is that
unpatriotic I guess if it's not welfare
must be evil fact is - Pelosi what's
unpatriotic is any solution that her
party that hapless band of fools didn't
come up with whether it's immigration
reform or tax cuts it's not it's just
not right unless it's done by the left
and that boy does it suck all right we
have to we have to play this SOT which I
just saw as Nancy Pelosi offering
Democratic suggestions for border
security and involves a lawn mower let's
sit down and talk this through and see
what makes sense not some commitment to
a promise that we're gonna build a mall
in Mexico is going to pay for it that's
never going to happen but let's talk
about where that a more serious
structure might be necessary we're
fencing will do or mowing the
so that people can't be smuggled through
the grass and that's something about
levees technology personnel I think this
is the rallying cry Jesse for the
Democratic Party to move on vo that lon
was the other mow the lawn and the
crumbs I mean it's just the whole host
of unforced errors from Nancy plus
they've lost the tax debate and their
messaging has been atrocious they've
positioned themselves as being against
people keeping more of their money and
you see it in the polls even Democrats
support for the tax cuts doubled from
nine percent to 18 percent rest of the
American public when you put it all
together I think it's now over fifty
percent won the other day said something
that I found very interesting about the
popularity in the tax bill he said he's
surprised the tax cuts weren't at ninety
percent popularity and I'm very glad to
hear you say that one that you would
actually admit that ninety percent of
the country wants to keep more of their
money
maybe the Democratic Party can listen to
the American people and start cutting
taxes to one respond if we have a poll
on ice cream apple pie and grandmother's
what do you think the results should be
if it was 50 percent you'd say what the
hell how can 50 percent of America not
like grandmother's Apple some grandmas
mothers are evil no we have a tax cut
that mr. Trump says is the greatest
thing ever and it's only now approaching
50% and according to the polls it's only
like a quarter of Americans who say
they've seen anything any kind of bump
in their pay so it's bad it's not right
so wrong and you think about it you
think about the realities that President
Trump says something and you guys play
Nancy Pelosi because you love to beat up
Nancy Pelosi oh my god
but Nancy Pelosi says something that
makes total sense which is the Mexicans
aren't paying for this wall he promised
during the campaign the Mexicans now
we're gonna have to pay for it and he's
saying oh you know what we have ways for
you to force you Democrats to paper why
don't
can say that's just crazy Dana
well I remember something that Chris
Tyra once said a few weeks ago I think I
was on the daily briefing show of the
podcast that the best thing that Nancy
Pelosi could do for the Democrats in the
midterms is wait until the 4th of July
recess and retire all right now she's
not going to run again a speaker and let
the new generation push it forward yes
yeah I mean this is I mean I think it's
just very obvious at this point that you
know the time has come and passed what
did the publicans need to say just let
Nancy Pelosi keep on talking to be quite
honest because she's not making any
sense and she says things that just are
completely nonsensical and probably just
sit there and go at least we've coming
up with ideas at least we're putting
forward legislation at least we want
people to keep more of their money to
reinvest into the market so she's really
like fighting kind of a losing cause and
doesn't have any support or any good
metaphors analogies examples mow the
grass or it could be she's on grass who
wouldn't uses that word anymore right
that's like from dragnet we found some
grass on them yeah one uses it
[Laughter]